all right our next guest by the way has
now been caught up in the Democrats
witch-hunt and it has cost him dearly
and personally former Trump campaign
aide Michael Caputo he's had to sell his
home to pay for legal fees associated
with the Russia probe and he's now
fearful that his kids futures are in
jeopardy over this now this week Caputo
had harsh words for the Senate
Intelligence Committee he told them this
quote what America needs is an
investigation of the investigators I
want to know who's paying for the spies
work and coordinating this attack on
President Donald Trump I want to know
who cost us so much money who crushed
our kids who forced us out of our home
all because you lost an election I want
to know because well GD you to hell
Michael Caputo joins us now you know I
know you're not the only one you said
what a lot of people feel I said this to
Rudy Giuliani the other night you know
yeah I watched whole pics from day one
in the Trump campaign I'm guessing I
don't know for sure she probably spent
more legal fees than she was paid last
year and I think that's the case for a
lot of people tell I want you to explain
how this impacts you and your family
well it all started well thanks for
having me Sean by the way but it all
started on March 20th 2017 when the the
House Intelligence Committee had a
public hearing where representative
Jackie Speier brought my name up and my
wife's name up in the hearing and called
me Putin's image-maker
the threats to our family came just one
after the other from their death threat
after death threat one guy called me
after that hearing on the phone and said
I know you're not home we're gonna burn
your house down with your wife and
children inside these death threats
haven't stopped since that day I had the
lawyer up shortly thereafter when it
became very clear that I was gonna be
pulled into the congressional
investigations and since then after a
house permanent Select Committee of
intelligence hearing in 2017 and then a
Senate committee hearing on Tuesday and
now I'm sitting before the Muller team
on Wednesday were at about a 125,000
I want to tell you I we were on our way
out of our out of our home Sean on our
way out because we couldn't have a home
like we had and make Buffalo money we
had to move to Washington to make
Washington money so I could pay the debt
that I had you know these 125 thousands
more I'm making a year out here in East
Aurora New York it's just you know
that's how much you know we don't make
that much out here we have a we're
wealthy and a quality of life you know
my deal with what happened yeah good sir
what happened Sean really surprising
because just one last thing we were
trying to do before we had to really
pack up was put up a GoFundMe and
between the time I told them to go to
hell and the time my check might go fund
me we had raised over $125,000 in $20
increments more than 2,000 donors I
would just shot by this I think it's a
good thing for people to see because
there are a dozen or more other people
who can't afford this we're really
having trouble and they need to know
that the Mokka people out there will
back them up I'm the first one actually
to see this I'm proof positive that
people are sick of this look nobody
should have to lose their home here's
the problem for you though they dragged
you into a legal case you must hire a
lawyer because you no person can fight
this on their own because as we learned
and talk a lot about this week they set
up perjury traps and if you don't answer
the right way then you're gonna be
charged with perjury if you miss
remember something you're gonna be
charged with perjury look at the
revelation we had Katherine Harrods
tonight and the unredacted portion of
the house Intel report where literally
nobody thought Michael Flynn was lying
nobody including Comey who lied about it
I'll tell you son you know I walked
right into that same situation of
Wednesday with the Muller team I was in
there three hours which was look I think
kind of remarkably short considering how
long people have been in there but they
aren't nice there they're in there
directed and they didn't ask me one
question that they didn't already know
the answer to
they weren't investigating they were
there to ask
we questions they knew the answer to I
don't want to call what it sounds like
because frankly I'm a little intimidated
by this they warned me that you know
they would be watching me on TV and they
know another tip do you follow
investigations another $25,000 for me
but I'm telling you Sean it's it's a
sticky wicket in there and they're not
pulling you in there for a barn dance
they there they're in there to put you
in a situation where you make a mistake
how sad they try to intimidate you we'll
be watching you on TV you know I've been
in this business 30 years and it's
obvious millions of dollars have been
spent to try and smear me in just
through the last recent weeks we're
either going to remain the United States
of America or we're gonna become
Venezuela yeah you're right we better
stand up there's abuse of powers out of
control
Michael I'm sorry what happened to your
family with all my heart I thanks a lot
you know mike go mike go funding is up
at Caputo illegal fund calm I probably
got to raise another 70 or 80 after this
interview probably another 150 but I've
had it Sean everybody's got to stand up
this thing's got to end I'm sorry
that this has all happened to you what
you described should put a chill up the
spine of every American Michael my best
to you and your family and we'll put up
that on that that on those screen when
we can